الدفعه الاولى من السيارات الاجنبيه تصل
ايران للمره الاولى منذ اكثر من اربعه
اعوام سيارات كوريه جنوبيه تليها يابانيه
وصينيه ستحتل عرش اسواق السيارات الحديثه
في البلاد
محمد مدير معرض للسيارات الاجنبيه بطهران
يبدو مهتما باستيراد السيارات حديثه لكنه
لا يتوقع ان يكون لذلك وقع كبيرعلى السوق
يعني دخول موديلات جديده لم تشهدها السوق
منذ سنوات لكن ولان العدد محدود فليكون
بالغ الاثر لا سيما انه تزامن مع تقلب
اسواق العملات
الاستيراد ترافق مع استمرار هبوط العمله
الوطنيه التي فقدت في الاشهر الثلاثه
الاخيره وحدها نحو 20 في المئه من قيمتها
ما يعني ان السيارات المستورده ستكون
باهظه الثمن مقارنه بنظيراتها المحليه
الاقل لجوده
في عام 2018 قررت الحكومه السابقه ايقاف
استيراد السيارات اثرا انسحاب واشنطن من
الاتفاق النووي بهدف الحفاظ على
احتياطياتها من العمله الاجنبيه
ورغم ان ايران انتجت نحو ميليون سياره
العام الماضي فانها عاده الاستيراد على
امل ايجاد السوق التنافسيه بين المنتج
المحلي والاجنبي من حيث السعر والجوده
ويشكل ذلك فرصه لاستعاده اموال مجمده في
الخارج بفعل عقوبته
طالما بقيه السيارات في ايران سلعه
للاستثمار لا للاستهلاك ستظل سوقها غير
مستقره
اتمنى اعداد السيارات المزمع استيرادها
محدوده فانه يؤمل منها الحد من حوادث
السير
فصانعوا السيارات المحليه
يدركنا عدم رضا المواطن عن جوده ما يصنعه
حاجز استيراد السيارات الاجنبيه
وتتجه لشراء من كوريا واليابان والصين
لكنها تبقي الباب مغلقا امام توريد
السيارات الاوروبيه والامريكيه
لاسباب يتداخل فيها السياسيون مع
الاقتصادي عمر هواش الجزيره طيران